♪♪♪♪
-Over.
-I just feel like...
-Just, like --
-I feel like --
-Don't rush into it. Yeah, yeah.
-Just so slowly.
I'm slowly starting to
trust you.
-Yeah. Okay, good.
-Like E.T.
Like E.T.,
and you're like Elliott.
-Here. I'll put some --
There we go.
Yeah. There we go.
[ As E.T. ] Seth.
-Hey, congratulations --
six Oscar nominations.
That's really exciting.
-Cheers, cheers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Hey, before we get started off
I saw what Max
did for you and stuff.
I kind of -- He kind of trie
to steal the wind
out of my sails,
and what I've done for you -
-You drew a picture, too.
-I did one for you, as well.
And this is...
-Yeah, great. It's like a --
-That's just your name
with a bunch of snakes.
-Great.
-Over the years watching you
I kind feel like
you're sort of like this
sort of venomous
kind of person who sort of
can't be trusted.
-Okay. Yeah, that's really nice.
Thank you.
-Yeah, no,
there's a bunch there,
and the "H" is made up of
kind of bendy snake,
which has got about -- See that?
-Yeah, got a bunch of tongues.
-Bunch of tongues in there
-Yeah. This snake -- And, again,
I don't want to be critical --
-Well, there's a striped snake
-Yeah, it looks like a --
-Very straight, tall.
-A carrot snake.
-And it just happens to be
the timing
was just perfect when I drew it.
There was a flying snake
that's going past.
in the background.
-Yeah. Oh, that's really -
Well, that means a lot to me
Thank you so much.
-Also, it happens to be
on the back of the
lovely welcome card
that you wrote to me.
-Look at that. Look at that.
I wrote a beautiful card to you.
-Yeah.
-"Welcome to the show."
-So I want that back.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, that's mine.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Thank you.
-[ Laughs ]
This is such a unique film
How does a movie
like this come together?
Because I don't feel like
studios say,
"We're looking for
a movie like this."
-No. Yeah. No, no.
I mean, those days are gone.
Yeah, I mean, you can't really
pitch this film.
-Yeah.
-I mean, you try -- You preten
I'm a studio exec
in Los Angeles,
and try pitching the film to me.
Hold on.
I'll just get into character
-Okay, and you want me to pitc
"Jojo Rabbit"?
-Yeah, you're me,
and I'm a Hollywood type.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"Eh, I make movies.
And boobies."
-Okay.
-"What do you got, kid?"
-I'll have a --
-Get out!
That was pretty much it.
-Yeah.
-So, I really was --
-It's based on a book, yeah?
-It's based on a book.
My mother -- she suggested
this book to me,
which it was really beautiful.
The book is a lot darker.
It doesn't have any jokes or a
imaginary Hitler in it.
This is what I felt was missing.
But there's a beautiful stor
there between a kid
who finds this girl living
in this house
and, you know,
a story about understandin
and about a little boy's
indoctrinated to hate
who learns to think for himself.
And it has
a very positive message in it,
and that's what
I was attracted to.
-And you play Hitler
in the film.
You also directed the film
I imagine that leads to
moments where
you are directing dressed
as Hitler.
-Yeah.
Yeah, that's...
[ Laughter ]
You've lost me.
You've lost my trust.
-That's fair. That's fair.
-No, that's -- I think the
overwhelming feeling
when you dress up like tha
is embarrassment.
-Yeah.
-And then, weirdly,
on set with the crew,
you become a lot nicer
all of a sudden.
You know,
you overcompensate, and --
But it's not an easy thing
to tell an actor,
"Hey, I think that was great
when you dressed like that
"Come through the door.
Next time, come through.
Say the line
a bit little quicker.
Get over to here.
This is just a suggestion.
I'm not ordering you to do this.
Okay?"
-The kids -- Here are a couple
of your wonderful actors,
Roman and Archie.
-Yeah.
-They were great.
-Wonderful.
Wonderful little Aryan kids.
-Just so much --
So much heart in this kid.
Really nice comic relief b
Archie over here.
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, they're beautiful.
Roman is -- yeah, he's a ver
incredibly beautiful,
sensitive kid, and, turns out,
an amazing actor.
Neither of these kids
had acted before.
Archie is -- I mean,
he really --
Every scene you see him in
he steals the show.
And he's just a character unto
himself, who's now, I heard,
is now in the reboot of
"Home Alone."
-Oh, that's exciting.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Oh, that's great.
-So good for him.
-Another scene-stealing
character
that was in another film o
yours, "Thor: Ragnarok" --
you played --
You were the voice of Korg
-Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How did that come about?
Did you sort of know
from the beginning
that you were going to
play Korg?
-I had no idea that I was gonn
play that character, actually.
No, it was just
something that --
Yeah, it was
a happy accident, I guess.
But that -- Yeah, I mean,
you know, it's --
That character is played by on
of the most amazing actors
and someone I very much
respect as a...
[ Laughter ]
Look, I mean, I will crowbar
myself into any of my films.
-Yeah.
-I don't pretend anymore.
-And it's nice now,
'cause we expect to see it
-You're like Hitchcock, but it's
a lot easier to find you.
-Okay...Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, congratulations.
Best of luck at the Oscars
-Thank you.
-So delightful having you here
Taika Waititi, everybody.